[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight the television news
business is a very small place some
might call it incestuous most of the
people who do this weird job for a
living know each other many have worked
together over the years those aren't
that many employers so it's not
surprising that a number of people on
this channel including me once worked
across the dial at CNN and as any of us
can and will be happy to tell you cNN
has always been a liberal place it was
founded by Ted Turner who's an
aggressive left winger but CNN was not
always naked ly partisan it used to be a
news network didn't always function as
it does now as a political campaign
that's a new development what changed
well the head of the company changed the
president Cena now is Jeff Zucker he's
responsible for the change here's how
one's described him on this program from
his shadowy lair hidden high above the
newsroom CNN secretive dwarf king
slithered to the intercom and summoned
his minions from across the cable empire
they gathered at his beckoning each with
talking points ready so if it sounds
like something out of Harry Potter
that's because in some ways it is you
won't see gargoyles at CNN headquarters
but you can feel the political ambitions
of the man who runs every detail of that
place since succor took over CNN almost
seven years ago it often feels like
every segment on that channel is
choreographed for maximum political
effect if you ever seen it you know
exactly what we're saying and it turns
out there's a reason it feels that way
earlier today the group project Veritas
released a series of audio and video
recordings it says we're made by someone
within CNN now as if cyanotic tape we're
about to show you we didn't call over to
CNN and asked them that they did not
respond but we have no reason to believe
any of this is fake the recordings are
about to show you indicate zuker is
dictating every detail of CNN's
programming and doing so with clearly
partisan objectives in mind here's one
example
this is hooker telling his minions how
to shape the coverage of Senator Lindsey
Graham of South Carolina Oh God
that's the standard that's the news
standard at the News Network the cable
news network
Lindsey Graham has appeared on Fox so
attack him
and so CNN did just that all while
pretending coverage was legitimate
here's Jeff Zucker telling his employees
that no matter what else is going on in
the world the impeachment of Donald
Trump which in effect is a symbolic act
since nobody believes he's going to be
convicted is nevertheless the only story
that really matters listen for a newsman
the distinct lack of clarity in those
instructions but the essence was clear
enough don't lose sight of what the
biggest story is and that's an order
well the message apparently has been
received by the people who work for Jeff
Zucker listen as a CNN it staffer
explains that he and the rest of them
know exactly what Jeff Zucker wants the
impeach receptors new developments every
day more shoes drop and it's like
there's just nothing we can do good
Zucker wants you
every single day to leave a top story
there's nothing we can do if jeff zucker
wants impeachment every single day
impeachment above all and so that's
exactly what they deliver day after day
despite the fact that Israeli anything
new to report not really and yet because
projection is the signature hallmark of
the left Jeff Zucker accuses other
people of trafficking and fake and news
hilarious listen to this serious about
this harrumphs one of the least serious
people least impressive people least
articulate people in public life ah even
as other employees can't take that
seriously listen to one of them laughing
cuz how can you not laugh it's just it's
out there it's like there's nothing
hidden at this point but it's also
poignant here you have a kid who works
there who thinks it's journalism and he
looks around and he sees people because
there are good people at CNN we know
that anyways work there knows the good
people who work there they're a bunch of
them who are trying to commit journalism
but the big boss Jeff Zucker won't allow
it
integrity be damned just do what Jeff
Zucker says whether it's true or not
it's not journalism of course it's the
definition of state media relentless
cheerleading relentless never-ending
shilling for the ruling class America
doesn't love it they don't watch it but
everyone in washington loves jeff zucker
not surprising Ravi Swamy is an editor
Etrian author of panic attack young
radicals in the age of trumpeting joins
the st. Robbie great to see you tonight
so look I don't have any problem the
opinion programming this is an opinion
show we conduct a lot of opinion
programming as I often say never attack
Rachel Maddow because she's not lying to
me she's just giving opinions I disagree
with if Jeff cookers out there claiming
that he is running a news network and
his employees are saying things like
there's nothing we can do if Zucker
wants impeachment we have to do what he
says I mean is that journalism I mean
that's the most interesting thing about
this right that there can only be one
story right every day there is one story
there's nothing else happening in the
world nothing else worth covering if
you're a journalist interested in
exploring some other subject please
don't please stop we don't do that here
right so that's frustrating obviously
for the people who as you said are good
journalists who work there and think
maybe some days Trump is not the top
story or the slightest minut new iota of
news pertaining to Russia or Ukraine or
whatever it is maybe there's something
else that's more bored to talk about
know the orders are at that camp well
that is such an excellent point in
whatever you know the falx of fox news
may have I can say with total sincerity
we've never once in three years been
told what to cover we don't have some
centralized Morning Call where the big
boss gets on and says this is the story
cover this it's like whatever you think
that's what they hire you is to make
these calls see then it's a command and
control system that's just itself seems
like a bad idea well and they act like
they're these perfect purveyors of
knowledge that can never air I mean I
disagree with things people say on Fox
because there's a range of people who
say them on that internally that's true
I agree there's nothing wrong with that
but these other networks some of them
these other mainstream news outlets they
act as if they are they represent some
sensible center position that is sort of
beyond reproach this it's different than
what you're doing right that what you're
doing is is is weird or strained what
they're doing is just purveying
objective information and they're not on
any one side I think the thing that's
happened over the last couple years
right is people have realized that's not
true they've stopped believing that sort
of lie that narrative lie right about
what other journalists do so why
wouldn't if you were seen in you just be
honest and say and maybe you have a
couple people who really are right down
the middle will
what serve your pick one or whatever but
you say the rest of these guys Don
LeMond in the Cuomo kid like there are
obviously partisans there's nothing
wrong with that
why insult us continue to insult us by
pretending other way exactly cuz you
actually can do good journalist as
someone with opinions in fact I couldn't
agree more most people do have opinions
right that's kind of the galling thing
here pretending that you're an objective
purveyor of the truth when we know you
have opinion that maybe that's the good
thing about all this it's now more out
in the open yes the more people realize
that no there are opinions and you
should take that with a grain of salt
when you're considering the information
you're being exactly stop lie and we can
get along yes
Robbie great to see you that pleasure as
project Veritas as footage does make
clear Jeff suckers regime at CNN is only
possible with the help of others at the
network so maybe Don Lemon could
disclose that but CNN makes it appear as
so we have 24 hours unbiased news that's
not true have a sense that Nick Neville
kids in some trouble tonight
unfortunately
author and columnist mark Stein joins us
to assess all of this what are you
making of what we've learned ern tonight
mark well it helps to confirm why CNN is
in the state it's in if you recall I
think this was the year before President
Trump came down that escalator CNN was
when nuts over the Malaysia Airlines jet
right leading up to their fantastic
theory that the jet had flown into a
black hole which you may recall there
respected journalists were advancing at
one point and you can say what you like
about that but that has a kind of
objective surreal nuttiness all of its
own as it's in that it's in the
tradition of a lot of tabloid Huk
stirring and other things but it's not
just putting yourself at the service of
one political party and doing the
bidding of that party
I think that's been a disaster for CNN
you talk about Jeff Zucker he has a
network to run and it seems to me a lot
of the things that are terrible about
CNN before you get to the bias it sets
look dreary compared I mean I say this
with whatever objectivity you take it
with but I think it sets look dreary
compared to Fox
I think it's anchors are not compelling
when it has big special events such as
it's rather curious LGBT debate the
other night when Joe Biden started
riffing on gay bath houses in theory
that ought to be must-see TV but it was
a ratings bust because of the way CNN
cover that so there are actual things
that there's a television executive Jeff
Zucker should be trying to correct and
once he's made it less bad in television
terms then if he wants to attend his
political biases he would at least have
accomplished his primary task which is
to be a functioning television executive
well that's the interesting fact of all
of this I mean CNN for all of its effort
to carry water for the Democratic Party
it that's not actually working this is
what is the point of this no it isn't
and and they're in this terrible trap
because they started as the first cable
news channel and they had a kind of USA
Today image people just thought of it as
something that's there when you go to
the airport it's there like USA Today is
outside your hotel room door when you're
staying at a Marriott or whatever when
you when you go to a foreign hotel in
Amman in Jordan or wherever they've got
they've got CNN International playing
over as you watch your breakfast in the
restaurant so they have this bland image
and yet at the same time they're hyper
partisans and they can't make those two
things align properly
I mean CNN is that right now is the most
irrelevant of the network's if you want
hard-core lefty propagandists they do
that again
they do that better than CNN I know much
better it's actually interesting I think
I mean I'm watching the gym every day
Mark's done great to see you thank you
for that thanks a lot Tucker